do you believe in love at first sight I
can walk by again if you want hey hello
my name is Nana and I think videos here
at BuzzFeed New York so here's a thing
I've always wanted to initially
conversation with men but I'm super
duper shy y'all but I tell myself what
is the worst that can happen
rejection but I mean that's okay cuz
life goes on anyway this video is
supposed to be about me going out into
the streets of NYC to pick up some men
uh
I chickened out I just couldn't do it
y'all I can't so I decided to get for
shy but extremely brave woman to do it
instead let's watch I'm shy because I'm
afraid of rejection when it comes to
guys I definitely have very very square
wheels I'm really like seriously hoping
to find BAE so fingers crossed I don't
think I will ever be ready so I'm just
gonna go ahead and do it now is there
any rule on pre-gaming this whole thing
just watching a cop come by this exact
moment shears lips silence
[Music]
we found I feel like I'm very obvious
huge I had a lot of caffeine this
morning so I'm just like giggly and
jittery in general okay hello
I seem to have lost my number can I have
yours you're really cute just but I'd
like to say hi are you single
okay that's okay thanks for putting up
with that sorry hi excuse me sir do a
second this is so rough tip number one
don't speak while we are on the phone
[Music]
I tried
all right so blob at first bite
I'm not doing this anymore hey guys
we're good what are y'all filming
[Music]
continue being handsome I can't I have
to go home hey I can kind of weird but I
think you're really cute thank you very
much do you mind if I get your number
sure um sorry I don't ever do this you
guys have any cigar myself yeah I do
actually
I don't ever use mine though but thank
you it's nice to meet you P no question
how was heaven when you left it no I
wasn't up to my expectations at all
that's why I left it it's like running
hey sorry this is probably really
awkward but I just saw you over there
and it's like always pretty cute
I was wondering like maybe I could get
your number
yes Jared Delisa list I'm gonna check it
out I think got it okay thank you sir
nice to meet you Jared absolutely you
could have gone a little bit better
probably those we're off seven worse
could've been worse but definitely no no
way say you didn't I did it I conquered
a fear today it's a good day
[Music]